no send this to a child the vast
majority of marriage is going to fail
well this is only 50 a lot of the
Millennials and people have the marriage
is dropping off because men are
realizing it's a really bad deal yeah
it's a terrible deal no view of a brain
is going to get married really you're
far better off
um we're made unmarried because just the
consequences of losing yeah kids you
lose your kids being unmarried but you
lose your financial assets and all the
rest of it that's the problem with
marriage so don't get married
um but most I'd say a lot of people
marriage is declining
um people are getting wise to the issues
and and problems to say it's not a
problem where over half of all marriages
end in divorce right to say it's not a
problem when it's three million kids
homes to say it's not a problem I'm up
to 44 of couples are now separate end up
in the family calls for 44. that's gonna
be my question 44 family courts of
couples separated ended up in family
court so if you get if you get separated
half the time you're going to go to
court yeah and the underlying Dynamics
allows so five to ten percent a year the
cases are increased and increasing this
is an Unstoppable Trend it's a social
Trend and then you only have a 10 chance
of getting your kids
I mean most guys don't I mean despite
our best Endeavors most days that we
also have bad is and nobody speak to us
they go oh my God you know because a lot
of times like oh I'll talk to people and
they'll just say you guys are just
harping on the issues um like I spoke to
one guy
um
who he really was just a cute like he he
really passionately just felt like we
were just never talking about Solutions
we're only talking about the problems
um but
I mean how this is horrible I'm like the
more I learn about this I don't know
what positive you could come out of this
they're on um do I have any positives
apart from the success stories that we
get which thank God are the 70 to 80 for
you guys I've got a really good team
there I've got the best team in the
country I've got uh I've got Nadine
who's who's our kind of lead case worker
she's amazing I mean absolutely amazing
um she's tough I call her lady balls is
her nickname
um but she's tough and we've got another
guy Dr Palin who's our kind of legal
Yoda I guess
um he's completely opposite to me
um and he's our he's our brain cell and
his knowledge of law is encyclopedic and
his ability to take on case we've won
judicial reviews we've got his case in
the high court at the moment uh he's got
a forensic ability to um you know to
disembowel cases and find legal points
of argument so we've got a really good
team so we're lucky in that with space
what do you say the guys that say oh
just find the rate girl it's the girls
that you pick it's the woman you pick
don't speak to me I but a terrible track
record of picking women's Army don't ask
me I'll say to my sons I can tell you
how not to do it I can't tell you how to
do it I would be the worst person in
fact my sons when I said set up a
vetting committee for me uh Pearl
because I'm not to be trusted out of my
own I'm a liability apparently so uh but
what do you say to people that say it's
it's just you guys just don't pick the
right women
um that's that's why this problem like
well we're going to push marriage
because it's you guys you're just not
picking the right women well listen I I
this affects everybody right it's like a
few people I said we we've we've we've
dealt with like Indian billionaire on
the books famous rock star
uh MPS Chief constables Royal protection
officers
um then you've got teachers
um you know you've got electricians
you've got I had the [__] Sky guy the
other day ended up I can't saw mascara
ended up having to give him advice the
ocado delivery guy you know the dpd guy
coming out you know and oh you you know
and you end up everywhere everywhere I
[__] go
I'm getting accosted by people so I
don't buy this as some kind of little
minority issue and if you think it's not
going to happen to you I promise you the
chances are statistically it will sooner
or later it will happen to you there's a
very very high probability given all the
other stats it could happen why do you
why do you say it's a high probability
when it's 50 50.
isn't that well it's not 50 50 is it I'm
saying relationship well if your
relationship breaks down okay there's a
chance you're going to end up in the
family court so that's like nearly
nearly 50 50 but you don't need to be in
the course I've seen people go to court
it's about relationship breakdown apart
from that is endemic
I don't blame them it's all too much so
heart attack can can fathers sign off on
their rates if they wanted to and not be
liable for anything the state will treat
you as a cash point
and it doesn't matter how much mother
the money uh money the mother earns it's
not taken into account she could be with
millionaire she could be a millionaire
doesn't matter your liability your child
support liability is determined while
the child support agency who are
ruthless who've got quasi-judicial pairs
if you don't pay what they say you owe
you can use your license you can use
your passport they can damage your
credit rating
etc etc they've got quasi judicial
powers so they are a again a starsy like
organization with terrifying power are
there any solutions to this because it
sounds like it it seems impossible to
change the law because why would a
politician in their right mind
take on this issue when they're gonna
not they're not gonna get elected
they're going to lose vote like I'm just
trying to think how would you even go
about changing it if you can't you can't
win the election we need a new I mean
and it goes on to another limited
sorry nothing
but we but but but we need a new form of
politics so a politics that actually
Embraces men and women Okay so
interesting I think Trump delivers
you know when he won he targeted working
White Collar main to an extent and I
think there's a huge demographic who
feel disenfranchised from our political
process who don't feel they're
represented
yeah if somebody came along with a
really smart political idea
you know I think there's a market a
particular is current age and a current
political crisis we live in on a
Perpetual basis and a political
corruption and whoever wins we lose
basically on every front being a [__]
pandemic be it during you know the
financial crash but whatever it is yeah
I wouldn't let these people went above
that another [__] country you know so
if you were if you were going to try to
change the law like I'm just going to be
done politically it's got to be
political it's got to be political the
only way you're gonna do it
but the issue is it's going to be hard
to get single mothers to vote for that
and all the they're all catering you
know well I have a great faith in the
British public that there is a
significant number
of mothers who actually
will support exactly what we're saying
and I think the vast majority of the
people I think are are support imposed I
think um
yougov did a poll and we did a poll with
conrades a couple of years ago in 2019.
we had like 80 public support
wow so the purposeful was it and also we
also campaigned for a minister for men
so we can coordinate his issues we can
all day a response to the Public Health
crisis surrounding male suicide you know
things like depression anxiety run a
campaign go to SOS Man Down
which is like peeling back the Cosmetic
veneer and looking at how toxic
masculinity has become not these men are
toxic but if you look at beneath love
Island and you leave it but you've
always kind of there's this kind of
really diseased
you know broken uh masculinity which I
think which is why Andrew Tate has
resonated with kids and with men because
he's the kind of like an antidote I
don't think he's a right antidote with
an antidote the feminism everyone's at
school being told boys have been told
you're a risk to women you're evil
you're dangerous we're stereotyping
you're demonizing you we've dead but we
label your fathers as Deadbeats
that's a reaction that's just a reaction
that people may want to reclaim their
masculinity how are boys discriminated
against in the school system well the
school system well let's just look at
the outcomes for boys I mean their their
educational records exam records their
failure rates are far more significant
than girls girls they're infinitely
better at school but also when you're
demonizing boys and telling them to
cross the road if you see a girl coming
out of the way when you're saying that
your potential problem that your
language can be abusive and that somehow
should have been spite of these nice
girls can do no wrong and yet I know at
my son's school they were doing drugs
they were squeezing the boy's backside
they were sending yeah sending sexually
inappropriate content this idea that
women don't do that [__] laughable oh
I mean you only need to go as many of
you know I was just banned on Tick Tock
and we are demonetized on a daily basis
on this platform if you want to help
please consider sending a super thanks
low every donation helps and it helps
make what we do possible